>> Sean: WELCOME BACK TO
"HANNITY."
BREAKING NEWS.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT, THE DOJ
INSPECTOR GENERAL, THE ONE WE'VE
BEEN WAITING FOR HAS COMPLETED A
DRAFT OF A REPORT AS IT RELATES
TO THE HANDLING OF THE CLINTON
E-MAIL INVESTIGATION.
HERE TO REACTION, OHIO
CONGRESSMAN, JIM JORDAN, RON
DESANTIS AND ALSO WITH US, SARAH
CARTER, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
SARAH, LET'S TALK TO YOU FIRST.
WE KNOW IT'S SUPPOSED TO COME IN
MAY OR APRIL, BUT THEY FOUND NEW
INFORMATION AS RELATES TO THIS.
NEW EVIDENCE AND THE NEW TRAIL.
WHERE ARE WE WITH THIS?
>> LOOKS LIKE IT'S WRAPPED UP.
WE WERE EXPECTING IT TO WRAP UP
IN MAY.
THEY EXTENDED THAT BECAUSE THEY
FOUND NEW INFORMATION AND IT'S
GOING TO BE IMPERATIVE FOR THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL HOROWITZ TO
GET ALL OF THAT INFORMATION INTO
THIS REPORT, WHICH I BELIEVE HE
DID.
NOW HE WILL BE RELEASING.
SO THIS IS GOING TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT.
THIS IS PART OF WHAT CONGRESS
HAS BEEN ASKING FOR ALL ALONG.
REMEMBER, IT'S THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL THAT HAS ALL OF THE
DOCUMENTATION.
THE 1.2 MILLION PIECES OF
DOCUMENTATION THAT CONGRESS HAS
BEEN PRACTICALLY BEGGING FOR AND
PUSHING AND THREATENING WITH
SUBPOENAS, THE DOJ AND THE FBI.
SO THIS REPORT IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
>> Sean: ON TOP OF THE LETTER
THAT BOTH OF YOU, RON DESANTIS
AND MARK MEADOWS WHO IS NOT WITH
US HAVE PUT OUT SAYING
MR. PRESIDENT, GET INVOLVED, YOU
HAVE TO TELL THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND YOU HAVE THE POWER
TO DO SO, 01.2 MILLION DOCUMENTS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE.
WE KNOW WITH THE LITTLE BIT
WE'VE GOTTEN, WE ONLY HAVE A FEW
OF THE STRZOK PAGE MEMOS TO
BEGIN WITH.
>> RIGHT.
COUPLE OF THINGS.
FIRST TO THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
REPORT, IT WAS MICHAEL HOROWITZ
THAT UNCOVERED THE PAGE-STRZOK
TEXTS WHERE WE LEARNED SO MUCH
INFORMATION.
IT WAS MICHAEL HOROWITZ AND HIS
TEAM THAT DETERMINED THAT ANDY
McCABE HAD MISLEAD PEOPLE UNDER
OATH.
SO WE'RE ALL WAITING FOR THIS
REPORT.
IF IT'S A DRAFT, THERE WILL BE
SOME REVIEWS THAT HAVE TO TAKE
PLACE.
THAT'S GOOD NEWS THAT WE'LL GET
THAT SOON.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, THE LETTER
THAT WE SENT.
WE'RE TIRED OF THE RUN AROUND
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
IT'S TIME TO TURN OVER THE
INFORMATION.
THE ONE WAY WE KNOW THAT CAN
HAPPEN IS FOR THE HEAD OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH, THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES TO TELL THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE FBI
DIRECTOR, GIVE CONGRESS A
SEPARATE AND EQUAL --
>> Sean: AND THEY HAVE TO DO IT.
>> YES.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ASKING THE
PRESIDENT TO DO.
>> Sean: RON DESANTIS, THIS IS A
KEY POINT.
AGAIN, WE ONLY GOT A SMALL
SAMPLING OF THE STRZOK-PAGE
MEMOS AND IT'S SO REVEALING,
INSURANCE POLICIES, HOW MUCH
THEY HATE TRUMP, HOW STRZOK IS
INVOLVED IN EVERYTHING.
LITERALLY INTERVIEWS HILLARY.
SHE'S EXONERATED.
WRITING IT BEFORE HE INTERVIEWED
HILLARY.
A FEW DAYS AFTER THEY EXONERATE,
RIG AN INVESTIGATION INTO HER,
THEY'RE INVESTIGATING DONALD
TRUMP.
THE TIMING OF THE GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS STORY IS BLOWING UP
IN THEIR FACE?
>> THAT'S WHY, SEAN, THE
COMBINATION OF THE I.G. REPORT
HITTING HOPEFULLY VERY SOON AND
THEN IF THE PRESIDENT PULLS THE
TRIGGER ON ALL OF THIS OTHER
INFORMATION, WE COULD HAVE THE
GUSHER OF INFORMATION THAT
PROVIDES ALL OF THE CLARITY THAT
WE'VE BEEN ASKING ABOUT ALL
THESE DIFFERENT QUESTIONS.
YEAH, YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
BEGINNING.
HOW DID THIS RUSSIA PROBE START.
VERY IMPORTANT QUESTION.
EVEN THINGS GOING UP INTO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
I MEAN, ROSENSTEIN WRITES AN
APPOINTING ORDER APPOINTING
MUELLER.
THE THING IS DEFECTIVE ON ITS
FACE.
HE WRITES A SECRET ADDENDUM, A
NEW APPOINTING ORDER AND THEN
THEY REDACTED MOST OF IT.
>> Sean: AND THIS IS AFTER THEY
RAIDED MANAFORT'S HOME.
THE TIMING IS BACKWARDS THAT
SHOWS CORRUPTION.
AND ROSENSTEIN SIGNING OFF ON
THE RIDICULOUS FISA APPLICATION
RENEWAL.
SARAH, HERE'S A BIG QUESTION.
I KNOW THE INSPECTOR GENERAL DID
RELEASE SOME OF THE STRZOK PAGE
TEXT MESSAGES.
SO REVEALING.
I DON'T KNOW MICHAEL HOROWITZ.
I KNOW HE'S APPOINTED BY OBAMA.
WHY SHOULD WE BELIEVE HE'S GOING
TO DO THEIR JOB?
THE EVIDENCE ABOUT HILLARY AND
COMMITTING FELONIES AND
OBSTRUCTING IS OVERWHELMING.
ANY AMERICAN WOULD GET
CONVICTED.
THE FACT THAT THEY EXONERATED
HER, IT'S OVERWHELMING AND
INCONTROVERTIBLE.
WHAT MAKES YOU THINK WE'LL GET
THE TRUTH FROM HIM?
>> I THINK THERE'S TWO THINGS
HERE THAT ARE VERY REVEALING.
ONE, LET ME START WITH YOUR
QUESTION, EVERYONE THAT I'VE
SPOKEN WITH, EVERY SOURCE SAID I
KNOW WHO KNOWS MICHAEL HOROWITZ
SAYS THIS MAN IS HONOR, WILL
STICK TO HIS GUNS.
HE WILL BE STRAIGHTFORWARD WITH
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE SAID THAT
ABOUT MUELLER.
>> NO.
WE SAW THAT WITH THE McCABE
REPORT.
HE WENT AFTER THIS ONE.
HE'S GOING TO GO AFTER COMEY,
LORETTA LYNCH IN THE TARMAC
MEETING.
>> Sean: STRZOK AND PAGE.
>> YES.
>> Sean: AND BRUCE OHR.
>> ABSOLUTELY, SEAN.
I WANT YOU TO THINK ABOUT THE
TIMING OF "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
STORY.
CROSS FIRE HURRICANE.
THEY KNEW, THE DOJ AS WELL AS
THE FBI, THAT THIS REPORT WAS
GOING TO COME OUT.
LOOK, CAME OUT TONIGHT.
RIGHT?
SO THEY NEEDED TO CYA AND THEY
WENT STRAIGHT TO "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" AND TRIED TO TELL THEIR
SIDE OF THE STORY, A LIMITED
SIDE.
>> Sean: "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
WILL TRY TO JUSTIFY AND MAKE
EXCUSES.
ALL THEY DID IS CONFIRM
EVERYTHING YOU'VE REPORTED AND
THE SHOW HAS REPORTED.
>> THEY CONFIRMED EVERYTHING
THAT'S BEEN REPORTED, THAT WE
REPORTED AND THEY ALSO GAVE AWAY
SOME INFORMATION.
THEY TALKED ABOUT AT LEAST ONE
MOLE, ONE
RIGHT?
>> Sean: RIGHT.
>> THAT MEANS THAT --
>> Sean: YOU'LL HAVE A BIG STORY
ON THE FBI INFORMANT THAT WAS IN
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, RIGHT?
AM I JUMPING THE GUN HERE?
I'M JUMPING THE GUN.
>> YOU MIGHT NOT BE.
>> Sean: WE SHOULD WE HAVE
FAITH -- GREAT WORK, BY THE WAY.
WHY SHOULD WE HAVE FAITH,
CONGRESSMAN?
SAME QUESTION, IN MICHAEL
HOROWITZ.
>> HE'S THE ONE THAT DID TELL US
WHAT ANDY McCABE WAS UP TO AND
UNCOVERED THE PAGE-STRZOK
MESSAGES.
THAT'S GOOD.
COMEY HAS BEEN FIRED.
WE'LL GET INFORMATION ABOUT THAT
IN THIS REPORT.
ANDREW McCABE FIRED.
WE'LL HAVE MORE ANSWERS.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHY PETER STRZOK
IS THERE.
A LOT OF THOSE THINGS THAT WELL
GET ANSWERS TO.
>> Sean: LAST WORD.
>> TRUST BY VERIFY.
THAT'S WHY THE PRESIDENT
RELEASES THESE DOCUMENTS, WE CAN